in this field in western France a
geologist is looking for gold french
mines have been shut for nearly 30 years
but with sewing crises of metals the
French explorers are back so inside this
kind of quartz in this kind of minerals
we can find some time a small trace of
gold it's a long-term work of
exploration before going to prepare a
possible mind this tile job says new
extraction techniques combined with high
prices could make french minds
profitable again for now they're just
digging samples but they hope to start a
real mine in five years time and they're
not the only ones to think so Australian
company variscan decided to invest in
the venture there is a logical potential
for metals in France and they took the
risk because the competition was very
strong and hard in Australia and they
were looking to to come to European
countries they've already hired a team
of young people for this 24 year old
geologist it's a huge opportunity
without this project he would have moved
to Australia or Canada good but instead
of going abroad I thought well France is
offering opportunities gathered since we
re starting from the whole sector for
each permit the French unit of variscan
is planning to invest between 3 and 15
million euros we are not looking for a
gold rush we are looking for
redevelopment of an industry these new
gold diggers will have to deal with
local resistance those who don't want to
see their landscape transformed by 09
Carolyn Kernan Bloomberg some pure
monomer france